I told you they were going to
[Music]
win the writer strike is over a
tentative agreement is reached and it
has now been ratified and it's a pretty
complete win for the writers they got
pretty much everything they were asking
for the
studios they
caved they gave the writers some version
of everything they wanted now would the
writers have liked some of these things
to maybe go a little bit further yeah
potentially but nothing was completely
Left Behind nothing was a case of like
okay well we got these things and we
didn't get that no they had a handful of
of major things they wanted
addressed and they've all been
addressed it's um it's very telling that
the studios caved as completely as they
did cuz at the start of this they were
all posturing oh we're going to starve
out the writers but as I talked about
before I think they made a number of
major
miscalculations uh one that I went into
in detail in this video uh was about how
they did not take into account how
social media works a lot of these
Executives have been around for a while
some of them uh if not in the exact
positions they were in were probably
using as a point of reference the 20072
2008 strike and social media was not
back then what it is now and the ability
for writers to reach out to the
consumers and drum up
support uh meant that the public was
very much not on the studio Side by and
large you know exceptions scattered
around but for the most part yeah no
nobody saw the studios as the good guys
in all this uh so there was that there's
also just the fact that they've been uh
starving out the wrers just by
underpaying them and understaffing the
writers rooms for so long I think they
underestimated the fact that they' kind
of already been conditioning the writers
to be able to survive in very lean times
they'd already been doing it cuz the
cont cont ract was bad well i' let me
revise that the original contract wasn't
bad but the studios and networks and
streaming services found ways to
circumvent the protections that were in
the old contract that's why the new ones
had to be done uh in any case why don't
we talk about what it was they got now
I'm not going to go through point for
point on every single thing that is in
this contract or at least the form that
has been made publicly available I will
put a link to it to in down in the
description if you want to go into full
detail and go over the thing with the
fine tooth comb and go through all the
legal ease but there are um four major
things that the writers wanted and that
they got and it's funny for as much as I
have talked about the writer strike I
didn't go into a ton of detail about
what it was they were seeking and what
it was that the studios weren't willing
to give them I've talked in the broad
Strokes in terms of like they won't
spend money on writers but you know
they'll give their CEOs 300 times what
the average worker for that company
makes but I didn't really go into
details of what it was that specifically
they were trying to accomplish
so let's do that now as I said there
were four major things first was a basic
raise the basic wages are set to
increase by a number of increments over
the next three years increasing in each
of the next three years so this is huge
especially because like this is
something that really just benefits e
everybody but especially for lack of a
better way to put it the people at the
bottom I mean a union isn't a hierarchy
so that's not exactly the best
terminology but like this isn't to the
benefit of screenwriters and showrunners
who were making hundreds of thousands if
not millions of dollars per project this
is what the basic Rank and file needed
desperately was for the basic wage to go
up and it is that was nice and
straightforward next up minimum Staffing
requirements for shows this one's really
important because this was one of the
ways in which writers were being
squeezed and opportunities for writers
both existing and especially for new
writers were all drying up because the
way it used to be um and this is not me
like going it was all good back then
like the entertainment industry has
always been messed up in one way or
another but the old model especially
when it came to television was that you
would get usually 20 24 26 episodes in a
season you needed a decently staffed
writers room to do that and they were
going to be working for quite a while to
get through that whole season that was a
decent chunk of work and it had enough
openings to give opportunities to new
and upcoming writers well these days
especially in the streaming era more and
more often shows are not 26 episodes
some still are
but increasingly new stuff that comes
out is 13 episodes 6 episodes 10
episodes and as these season sizes were
shrinking so too were the size of the
writers rooms so suddenly you just flat
out have fewer opportunities there were
fewer openings and even the people who
could get these jobs they weren't
lasting as long because a gig that you
get to work on S a season that's only
six episodes long is not going to pay
your bills for as long as a gig that is
26 episodes so now they have minimum
Staffing requirements and interestingly
it scales up depending on the size of
the production so for instance um it is
a bare minimum of three writers up to
anything six episodes long once you get
to say 13 episodes or more you have to
have six writers and I think it's five
for that space in between uh between 7
and 12 so they have that scaled up they
taking that into account so they're not
going to be overloading a six episode
series with you must have six writers in
that when that frankly might not be
practical but three writers is probably
a reasonable thing to do and it's just
going to provide more opportunities for
writers and it's going to keep networks
and streaming services from squeezing
the writers they had and forcing them to
do more work under tighter deadlines
than was standard for the industry so
it's going to make it a lot harder to
Crunch Riders rooms cuz you can't get
away with understaffing them the way
that they were trending towards this
next one is actually kind of huge I I
think the one people are going to be
talking about the most in a lot of ways
is AI I'm saving that one for last but
next up a bonus structure for streaming
shows based off viewing
numbers this is really big
because streaming services
do not make their viewing numbers
public or more accurately they are not
required to now sometimes they will
either if they are uh justifying the
cancellation of something they might you
know put some stuff out you know oh well
you know it was like number 10 out of
the releases this week or maybe they
will go into specifics not too often
there if something's a huge hit they
might give specific numbers to back that
up but they don't have to do that they
do that when it's to their advantage and
that already kind of put everybody on
the back foot honestly in a lot of ways
and it's one of the main problems with
streaming services and again I might I
I'm going to have to do a longer video
at some point talking about how all this
stuff is is just messed up and getting
worse and falling apart but one of the
fundamental things about the streaming
services is they don't have to disclose
that that is in contrast to uh cable and
network shows which do have to disclose
their viewing numbers now I actually
think that's kind of messed up I don't
think any business should actually be
permitted to keep what is the basic
fundamental data on which the entire
thing runs that secret especially when
that information is made public in
comparable companies like I honestly
think there should be legislation
addressing this so that they're not
allowed to just keep this secret but
that isn't the case yet I don't think
anybody's even pushing for that at the
levels where it would need to happen so
barring that this is good because what
they have arranged for is for the wga to
receive confidential viewing numbers so
that its members can receive appropriate
bonuses and I'm going to underline
confidential the wga is going to have
access to data that is not being made
public
so that's massive and that's a big part
of why if you worked on a streaming show
as a writer you didn't get bonuses based
off it being really successful cuz you
couldn't prove that it was cuz you
didn't have access to the numbers the
wga now will get access to those numbers
so they can fairly compensate writers
who work on something and that that then
goes on to be incredibly successful good
excellent and as I said kind of a big
deal given how much these streaming
service guard this information and then
finally the juiciest topic and
supposedly the one that was the biggest
sticking point at least in terms of
specific language because this was
something that they really needed to be
sure that they got right cuz loopholes
in this were going to be exploited and
maybe there still are some loopholes
we'll see AI so there's I'm not going to
again I'm not going to go word for word
through the whole thing but there's a
handful of points in regards to AI that
I think were very smart measures for the
wga to put into place first up AI cannot
be used to rewrite literary material and
an AI generated script or an outline
cannot be considered Source material for
the purposes of creative rights or
credit so the studios and networks can't
just have J chat GPT throw together an
outline or script and then hand that to
a writer and say here put this together
they also can't take a book or a novel
and throw that into chat GPT and tell it
hey turn that into a scpt script format
they are not allowed to do that now that
does not mean that AI cannot be used in
any way there's actually a couple of
ways in which it can be used now there
can certainly be some AI generated
materials provided to the writer that is
laid out now as I said it can't be the
basis for the script but if they wanted
to use AI generated materials as like
here's something to give you a sense of
the flavor of what we're looking for or
here's like some reference material that
we generated through AI that we think
would be helpful like lore Concepts or
you know more General uh ancillary
material that can be AI generated but if
it is AI generated that fact has to be
disclosed to the writer and to the wga
and a writer has the ability to choose
to make use of AI if they do that they
have to do so with the consent of the
company hiring them cuz the company can
also say like we don't want you to use
Ai and it's and it's not going to allow
the writer to throw their writing
assignment into Chad gbt and then Crank
that out they're not allowed to do that
either but if the writer wants to make
use of AI decides that it's a tool that
they can find helpful for what it is
they are doing and if the company hiring
them consents to that that is
permissible what is not permissible is
the writer cannot be required to make
use of AI as a tool in the writing
process so but is there and available
but only with the consent of both
parties involved those parties being the
writer and the company hire them both of
them have to be okay with making use of
AI and only then can AI be used I don't
even think that's a major capitulation
on the part of The Writers Guild it
basically gives veto power to either
side and is basically going look if both
sides are okay yeah that's fine as long
as nobody's going behind somebody's back
and undermining it and or requiring it
and while I don't think that's
necessarily a great thing creatively if
that actually is something that happens
in some cases where it does get used
because all sides agree to it that's a
creativity problem as far as the issues
that the contract is meant to address
fair enough and finally writing done by
wga members and union members cannot be
used to train AI That's also kind of big
one because these uh AI programs are
only as good as what you train them on
and that becomes a big issue uh just in
general with any creative Works whether
it be art whether it be writing whether
it be literally anything because
whatever you train it
on you've kind of stolen somebody's work
and have not compensated them for that
and this is pretty much forbidding the
um Studios from using Union writers work
to do that are they still going to train
AI on something who knows what
fanfiction they could if they wanted
like they shouldn't they shouldn't they
shouldn't be able to but like they
will cuz the wga contract can only cover
wga members
so I feel that this is a pretty good
coverage of I think reasonable uses of
AI and looking at how it could have been
used and ways in which it could have
undercut and undermined the work of
writers and the future of writing in the
industry I think they covered it pretty
well now like I'm not an expert uh and I
don't know a ton about contract law so I
don't know what loopholes might be in
the specific wording not my place to say
but overall again I'll come back to what
I said in the first place they won and
got pretty much everything that they
wanted that just leaves
the
actors and at time of recording it was
announced earlier today that there is a
meeting between sagaa and the amtp on
Monday and I will be very surprised if
there is not at least a tentative
agreement in place by this time next
week because with one of the two hurdles
to getting anything done uh now cleared
the Studios have a massive incentive to
settle with the actors as quickly as
possible so everybody can get back to
work it would make no sense for the
studios to finally cut a deal with the
writers and then be all bullheaded and
obstructionist with the actors because
that's still going to leave them in
largely the same position yeah sure the
writers can start getting to work again
and generate your scripts but you know
if people aren't able to get in front of
a camera and actually act them out then
there's only so much work that can
happen you're basically looking at only
being able to resume pre-production and
that's it right now so it's certainly in
their interest to settle with the actors
quickly and I think it's going to be
very much the same situation they are
probably going to give the actors
basically everything that they are
asking for because what is there to hold
out on if they gave in this completely
to the writers why would they not also
do so with the actors they tried to hold
out they tried to hold out on these um
requests demands however you want to
consider them they tried to just give
them basically almost
nothing and it didn't work and now
they've just got there tail tuck between
their legs they're coming in going fine
can we get back to work now our
shareholders are really breathing down
our nexts I bet they
are this is all incredibly
gratifying there's a lot of stuff going
on in unions right now that
is
encouraging not just this stuff uh one
of Marvel's uh Studios the um one of the
special effect Studios has voted to
unionize
good good uh in general across the
industry special effects workers are
some of the most exploited labor in the
industry and they're pretty much never
unionized this is good they should be uh
with Marvel and Disney especially
because they are notorious at this point
for cracking the whip on uh on their
teams and the thing is they're not even
getting good results out of that because
they're not giving people the time they
need to do the work correctly you know I
might have said that the last three
episodes of She-Hulk were the best
episodes of That season and they were
they were pretty good but you know
transform back to Jennifer why you are
very expensive oh sure but wait until
the camera is off you the visual effects
team has moved on to another project
yeah you don't get to make that joke
Marvel
Disney so I'm glad they're unionizing we
got stuff going on with Auto Workers
right now with them striking I wish them
the best of luck too there has been a
big upsurge in the strength and power
and showing the importance of unions
this
year and I'm really here for
it unions if you hadn't guessed my
general position on them are amazing and
wonderful and necessary
in most
Industries nearly all any industry of
size honestly because the ability to
exploit labor in the absence of a union
we have seen what that looks like we've
been seeing it for decades
now and it's not
good this is though this is
fantastic the writers have
won and I feel
good what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills and enables me to do this
as my living even if you can't help me
out that way like share subscribe those
are also pretty helpful don't worry too
much about it
though what I really want you to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are valid you are
loved workers of the World
Unite until next time this Council
is
[Music]
adjourned shout out to the patrons who
helped make this possible in particular
I want to thank Robin Moore Zubin Lola
goddess Elida Tac the thing that goes
doing to the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures rrick Bogden Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
kabx the poodle Robin Powell te love
Tracy scrapit angry caspero Dave Hall
and Roselyn Bennett there's being able
to hear me try and pronounce your name
plus a whole bunch of other rewards in
the patreon you can check out the tiers
but um if you are already on the list
thank you so
[Music]
much
down